Bangladesh was once a major exporter of
wild frogs for fine dining restaurants
in Europe and the U.S but shipments were
banned in 1989 due to Rapid decline of
frog population as well as an increase
in Farmland pests such as mosquitoes
now Bangladeshi frogs are facing a
different kind of threat this time from
plastic poisoning a new study by the
international Union of conservation of
nature says 15 out of 47 species of
frogs here are under threat
is
many fat frog species are already on the
brink of Extinction plastic and
macroplastic pollution are emerging
issues you can see how people are
dependent on it on a daily basis this
has become a plastic era
Professor tariq's University also
discovered microplastics and 83 percent
of fish it studied we have even
discovered microplastic in the muscles
of various fish that is the edible parts
which means we are already consuming
macroplastic through the food chain in
another study scientists found an
abundance of pollutants in surface water
and underlying sediments of lakes and
rivers in the capital Dhaka
we hardly get fish nowadays it's because
of the various pollution reversal canals
due to pollution fishes don't breed as
they used to they are not able to
survive anymore in these polluted Waters
experts say frogs have vital role in
controlling mosquitoes that carry
diseases such as malaria cases of dengue
fever have risen alarmingly here in
recent years
researchers involved in the studies at a
high level presence of microplastic and
frogs poses a Potential Threat to
biodiversity and crop production in
Bangladesh scientists say that the rise
in disposable plastic uses is creating a
pressing challenge for food safety as
microplastic accumulating in the marine
food chain tanvi chaudry Al Jazeera
Dhaka